لا اله الا
من
ص
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه الصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اما بعد كونتين ان الوجيز
في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
صيام التطوع
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول المؤلف
صيام اكثر شعبان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
شعبان
رمضان
عائشه رضي الله عنها بخاري مسلم ما رايت
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم استكمل صيام
شهر قط
الا شهر رمضان
وما رايته في شهر اكثر منه صياما في شعبان
عائشه
الله صلى الله عليه
‏said and I have not seen him fast more
in any other month
the month ofان
so
he would never fast an entire month from
start to finish
any
ضانceptان
however are some would more
of the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم fast the
fast that is most well for that would
always
keep as
‏and we all know that right so these
narrations areing to add to that would
always if nothing else fasts and
thursdays
but however he would also fast
additional days and he would choose and
he was very judious in
‏add
comm
and
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
النفس لها اقبال وادبار في الخير لها
اقبال بال وادبر فالمؤمن
يغتنم اقبالها
بالخيرات
و يحجم ادبارها
لما تدبر النفس خلص يجعل لها سنه لا تنقطع
عنه عنها واما اذا اقبلت وكانت في اقبالها
وهبوب رياحها فانه يغتنم تلك الرياح ذا
‏how going to be next month after you're
not going to be able to pr if you are
going to be more
enthusiastic today than tomorrow or this
week next week it's not something you
can there are a lot of different things
that play which go into a person's
enthusiasm or lack there and
‏of the person human being ne has its up
days and and down days has good day bad
day has its days when it is extremely
enthusiastic and has its days when it is
barely making the bare minimum and so
what the believer's job is to do is to
gauge himself and place for himself a
minimum that in its wor day his ne will
not
‏and
come this prop
would
always
days was
‏morey more
ener moree
more more
and so would always himself
things could do during this time now
there is another narration that we will
get to with to not f
point
that the propit
[Silence]
whatever day of the week or month or
every other day or what have you
narration does not apply to that this
narration applies
يقول المؤلف الاثنين والخميس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
Thursdays and
this is what would
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول عن اسامه بن زيد
قال ان نبي الله صلى الله عليه وسلم كان
يصوم يوم الاثنين والخميس وسئل عن ذلك
يعني سئل عن تعليل ذلك لماذا فقال ان
اعمال العباد تعرض يوم الاثنين والخميس
والحديث عند ابي داوود في سننه
‏and th would
and
[Silence]
كان يصوم كان كان
هذا فعل ماضي يدل على الاستمرار عند
الاصوليين وايضا
كان
وفعل المضارع
كان يفعل هذا يدل على الاستمرار
فياخذ من هذا العلماء
ان قول اسامه كان يصوم يوم الاثنين
والخميس يعني على الدوام دائما كل حياته
الا ان يعرض عارط من مرض او سفر او ما
شابه ذلك
اسامه زيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
Thursday and was asked about this he was
asked as to the reason for this why
these two days why not Tuesday and
Friday why not Tuesday and Wednesday why
Monday
صلى الله عليه وسلم
present
‏of
the week right twice a week so
3 days later thday and so a person
are presented
before
on Thursdays
الله
ang
[Silence]
‏him was
time
right and so a person why twice a week
we have
two angels
that right our good and bad deeds but
those two angels have
two other angel one for the and
‏and
time they happ to all be present because
the two for day time descend as the two
for night time prepare to and they all
stay for the prayer which is why the
longest recitation
in in
من صلاه الفريضه
فجر قران الفجر الله سبحانه وتعالى
one of these days
present
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد